Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Reading Your Comments.
I LOVE SENPAI, YES I DO
HE'S FOR ME, NOT FOR Y-
[Kaboom]
'Mark, quick! If you don't crash onto the folding table in the next five seconds'
'the entire world will explode!'*boooooooom*☺☺☺☺
*Demonic laughter*☺☺☺☺☻☻☻☻☻☻☻♥♦♣♠•◘○◙
*Demonic Laughter echoes*thumping*
*Earth explodes*
'Oh oh! I got one! Furiously suck on a banana, like you mean it!'
O-okay...
MARK (Off-camera): Matt, Matt!
MARK: Uh, hi, can I suck you?
MATT: No!
MARK: Just a little bit? MATT: No!
MARK: Please! MATT: NO!
MARK: Fans want it!
MATT: Nonono, nono- stop! Stop!
'You say you're half Korean, but what is the other half?'
Irish!
There's no other answer to that, it's just true!
'Mark, tell us another embarrassing story! The last one was great!'
Well, I'm so glad that you got so much enjoyment
out of my embarrassing life.
Let me just conjure up another one to lessen your opinion of me!
Alright, so here's one that still haunts me to this day.
Um, I- I-
In senior year of high school, I was first chair of the trumpets section
-which means that I got all the solos,
and I was also in Marching Band, so in
the show, there was a point at the VERY beginning of the show-
where I had a solo, and I had to play infront of
everybody else, and for some reason, I got so nervous
everytime  I went up to do it, because the show was like-
*gasp*
"BAAAAAAAH!"
aaaaand then it got really quiet, and then I was in a circle and everyone was orbiting around me
and I had to go -
*gasp*
"duh duh duh duh duH duh duh duh" (Trumpet noises)
- and I can't even remember the fingerings for it, but
*gasp*
The unfortunate thing is,
everytime in practice, EVERYTIME in practice,
I got it perfectly right!
*laughing* But then- *hah* - whenever we were doing a show for a competition,
EVERY SINGLE TIME -
I completely flubbed it...
Like, absolutely the worst, like -
*Mark squeaks like a dying squirrel*
And that was the start of our show,
for EVERY SINGLE SHOW - for the entire Marching Band season.
But one redeeming thing is that when we actually went
to the National competion,
I got it right!
But only once!
When we went back again,
*gasp*
I flubbed it again...
God damnit, I - ughhhhhhh
"Mark, will you be attending vidcon? If not, you should do it for the fangirls, Mark! Do it for the fans!"
Well, you don't need to BEG,
I am going to go to vidcon-
so you don't need to worry about that-
It's real nearby -
*gasp*
It's, uh, down in Anaheim, which is just
outside of L.A.,
and, oddly enough, Hank Green was over at my house the other day -
I thinkkk he put up a video where I was - *censors* -ing with *censor* *unintelligible noise* face,
which is probably very disturbing. If I find it, I'll put a link in the description below.
But- anyway,
got to hang out with him, so that was cool!
"Hey! Recently, I've had to deal with a breakup. Do you have any suggestions for getting over it?"
Uhhhhhhhhh...
Man, why do people come to me for serious advice, I'm not the guy to DO that!
*sarcastically* LAWYER UP, HIT THE GYM, DELETE FACEBOOK, Facebook up? DELETE THE GYM!
HIT YOUR LAWYER!
I don't know..
I mean, everyone's had a breakup at some point, so I can't really say what's the best way to go
about it, ummmm...
Eugh!
The only thing that I can say is that even though this breakup seems horrible
right now, and seems like the end of the world,
life DOES go on.
I mean, everyone in the entire world who's been in a relationship
has probably broken up at some point,
and it's probably been devastating and it's been very bad
and it IS an emotionally traumatic experience.
But, life does move on.
So you just have to find a way to improve yourself
because a lot of people, when they go through a breakup
like, they lose like, a lot of what they had in their life
so you got to like, find yourself again.
So, it is hard
and I'm not the best at moving on from that sort of stuff,
so I may not be the best for advice
but all I can recommend is try to improve yourself through it
and try to do self-reflection on what you need as a person
and then try to get back out there.
But I'm no good!
I'm a big doofy-do!
Hahaha!
'What happened to the mountain of dildos?'
I will not have my dildo purchases ques-
habits- purch- que-
I'm not gonna spend
what could literally be hundreds of dollars
on dildos
just for a two second gag,
where you guys see a mountain of dildos.
There's no way in hell I'm doing that!
'Mark, you better read this comment and smile for me'
'or imma butt stab you in your face. :3 Love you!'
Wait, okay. Hang on a second here.
Are you- wait. Are you saying you're gonna...
You're gonna, you're gonna stab...
me in the face with your butt??
Are you,
you,
uh,
You're gonna stab...
my face into my butt??
You're going to...
You're gonna, you're gonna stab-
You're gonna hold a sword
in between your buttcheeks
and then stab me in the face?
Is that what you're gonna do?
Okay...
'Team Cap or Team Iron Man?'
Team Iron Cap!
I dunno, who cares? It's gonna be a cool movie!
Team Underoos! That's whose team I'm on.
'Mark! Do the thing where you turn your feet backwards!'
HOOKAY!
MATT: Mark, stop! I'm not sucking anything!
MARK: No, I need-
MATT: Stop!
MARK: -you! Come on!
'Mark, I have a lot of scars on my abdomen too.'
'How do you deal with the insecurity of people judging your scars?'
'Mine are from my intestines rupturing.'
'I have had 9 surgeries and are in the hospital for 3 months.'
'Hope you see this! :)'
Whoah.
That is, that is pretty intense.
So I've got a lot of scars from uh various surgeries like my
tumor removal and them my subsequent intestines ALMOST rupturing.
Mine did not rupture, but mine got close.
But it's okay.
Um...
To be honest, I've never been insecure about my scars.
I consider them pretty badass
and I'm proud of them.
They're really cool.
Mine are-
m- um,
one's weird because it's like I have a second belly button
but that's okay.
Um...
You could just make up battle stories about it
like I tell people I got stabbed by a rhino
through my abdomen
and that's how I got these scars
or, I was in a war-torn country
Rambo-ing it and trying to defeat terrorists or something like that.
I mean, at the end of the day, it's your body
so, like it's the only one you've got
so you gotta be proud of what you have.
So, like, just be you!
Accept the fact that this is you now,
even though you have a bunch of scars.
Like, scars are not bad, scars are not ugly.
Scars are just showing that you've lived life
and you've been through a lot more than other people have.
So, be proud it.
Be proud of who you are and be proud of your body!
'Mark! Don't jump in the pool!'
Okay.
'Mark, calm down.'
'Mark, don't sing this comment in a heavy metal fashion.'
Okay.
'Can you do the Charlie Charlie Challenge?'
Okay!
(Goddammit...)
Charlie, Charlie, are you there?
[CHARLIE: Yes, what is it?]
[Mark and Ryan freak out]
RYAN: AH GOD NO I CAN'T DO IT I'M SORRY
RYAN: I REALLY CAN'T DO IT THIS TIME!
'Do you plan on playing That Dragon, Cancer for us?'
Uh, yeah I do, actually.
It's been on my list for a while,
I just haven't gotten around to it.
It's, it's like a 2 hour long game.
And also, like, when I play that game,
I know that game is gonna be emotional for me,
because my dad died from cancer
and so it's obviously going to have a lot of
like, emotions for me and dredge up a lot of memories.
So that's gonna be a, um...
That's gonna be like, a serious video.
That's gonna be a very serious ordeal
and I wanna make sure I go into that in the right mindset
and that I have enough time to appreciate all of it
and I take the time to record that for you guys
And I will! I promise I'll get to that soon
but it's just...
I, I gotta build up the nerve to do it first
because those are experiences in my life that are a very dark time
and, you know, I've moved on from it.
I'm, I'm fine now, you know.
I- I don't, I don't really dwell on these thoughts now, but
you know, going back to those times,
back when my dad had cancer and going through that-
And I know it's not about a parent having cancer,
I think that game is about a child having cancer.
And that's like, even worse. So...
We'll, we'll see when that time comes.
I'll probably record it some time this week
if you guys really want to see it, but
it's gonna be...
It's gonna be an emotional time, so just prepare for that.
Alright? Cool.
'Mark! In all seriousness will you go on a date with me?'
'I will make sure you shall not have a bad breakup with anybody else for the rest of your life!'
*heavy breathing*
Oh god!
Ryan, lock the doors!
[softcore porn noises]
RYAN: Mark, she's serious this time!
[hardcore porn noises]
RYAN: I'm dead.
[laughter]
Okay! That's all the time I've got for Reading Your Comments.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you for writing your comments down in the comments section below!
I know things got out of hand last week
but I was very busy
with a whole bunch of other stuff
that I can't tell you about yet.
But it's cool! And it is coming out
probably in this fall.
Because it's THAT big of a project that we're working on.
But we'll see it!
And we'll be back on schedule in the next few videos.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always,
I will see YOU.
In the next video!
Buh-bye!